[Music]
hello and welcome to scitrek how are we
doing we're doing quite well how are you
jay
i'm very very well just remembered
got kids knocking around so i'm gonna
put my headphones in
okay so today
i am joined by my good friend my
resident american
stormy
and we're gonna be talking about
everything star trek mainly what is the
best star trek series
and maybe comparing the original star
trek or the classics to the
modern
star trek
so first of all
welcome and stormy how are you doing sir
how are you i am dodging umicron like a
[ __ ] man
just hitting my stick
i'm in my fear bunker
here in
california
yeah hey we've had some snow today so
i've got all christmassy i might crack a
bottle of uh oh wow mulled wine open
later we've got our first snow of the
year we never get snow this early so
it's going to be a lovely winter we
rarely get water
i know 100 degrees centigrade
it's hell on earth it is hell on earth
we're not talking
pandemics and we're not talking
christmas just yet
um
instead we're going to be talking star
trek
so first of all let's just go on the
classics
the original series tng d space nine
voyager all those what is your
favorite star trek series and and why
do you have a favorite
uh my favorite is definitely a deep
space nine uh
there's a bunch of reasons for one thing
it was uh it went against uh character
essentially for uh star trek series it
was dark it was messy it showed the
undercarriage of uh the federation
uh i think it was one of the best series
on television regardless of sci-fi or
whatever the genre was of a father-son
relationship
you know
that and especially in the black
communities you see
if you hear it from their perspective
their point of view it's like
we've never seen that before because it
was really
i mean you know
huh
the cisco in a certain relationship yeah
yeah yeah jake cisco and yeah and they
they just loved each other no matter
what crazy dabbo girl jake dragged in
for the night you know
that's some good dumbo girls
i want to learn how to play that game
i want to learn how to win that game oh
hell yeah
um
i think my favorite though is is the
next generation
but because that was the show that was
it's like my star trek i watched the
original series when i was little
tiny little boy
um but i you know it was it was
already 30 years old when i was watching
it you know so it was really quite dated
um
and then but then the tng came along the
next generation and i was watching them
new every week and i'd never seen it
before so the brand new series was
coming out i was having to like wait for
it we can you know um and then episodes
like
um um best of both worlds just blew my
mind you know it was just like that was
the
you know some of the the
best telly i'd ever seen you know
characters like data and you know i just
adored
um i've really fancied diana troy and um
you know it's just like this and i mean
i love the first couple of series where
they um
we'll talk about woke and stuff a bit
later but
it was like in the first couple of
series of the next generation all the
little short skirts and their low cut
tops and the uniform down the trail you
know it's like for a boy at my age oh
yeah yeah yeah
this is the greatest thing in the world
it's like
you know i absolutely loved it
yeah just because you know i just fawn
over deep space nine doesn't mean the
next generation was just
awesome you know i mean it was
i mean it at the time in 19 was it 87
when it started it went where uh no tv
series went before you know that's
definitely
you know so i actually put this question
out on facebook a lot and stuff and and
some people did just their answers i
said what's the best star trek and some
people's answer was star trek
it's all
brilliant great and i'm like yeah but
not all star trek is equal it just isn't
um
if i was guessing then a phaser against
your head what is the best star trek
series
though would it be deep space nine still
is that why it's your favorite because
it's just the best of the genre
um i think it's the best of the genre
but um
i'm telling you dude
lower decks
is just
oh my god that's controversial oh
there'll be comments oh they're yeah
they're you're gonna get all the hate
mail man but i really love lower decks i
mean it is just so
wrong i mean in so many ways for all the
right reasons almost now talk about
going against your standard um
trek flavor
lower decks i mean you know you have the
the the functional dysfunctionals in the
in the bowels of the cerrito
running around with their panic attacks
and you know
and mother dog you know mother daughter
angst it's
just great
you know it's everything the orville
could have been
i know i love the oval
we'll get away from that though
lower decks that's a different video but
lower decks i will say to you i love
lodex i think it's brilliant because i
think it's um
but i don't really consider it star trek
it's not canon
it isn't canon the stuff that goes on in
that series you know
and
more importantly though
to me it's like it's a love letter to
the next generation
i think it is yeah yeah it's not really
um it's not really star trek in like the
the strictest sense of the word it's
it's like a you know it's yeah it's a
love letter to star trek
and i adore it i absolutely adore it but
um but yeah
if i you know like so when i turn on
paramount plus here in the us
you know um
if i have right now my choices are
prodigy
uh lower decks or the new uh uh
discovery uh
or season four episode
i started off with uh lower decks
because like what in the hell are they
gonna do this week i do love that [ __ ]
it kind of reminds me of archer in a
little bit but without all the phrasing
the star the style is very much like
right right cartoon series definitely i
love the opening sequence
yeah which was not you're right which
was not uh the battle of wharf three
five nine it was because there's three
cubes involved there's only one at war
three
that's a battle we don't know about so
there you go
all right
my my favorite if i'm going to say my
favorite series is tng if we're going
back to proper star trek right but i
honestly think i'm with you the best
series of star trek is deep space nine
and it's that gets a lot of it doesn't
get a lot of love sometimes deep space
nine
um but i'm with you i think it broke the
mold of what star trek was right you get
episodes
we'll go talk about the series in
specifics but um in the pale moonlight
with cisco
broke the wall down and cisco was
talking about this plan that they've had
to drag the to get the romulans involved
in the um dominion war and it really
showed it to the dark side not only of
cisco but of the federation
and i don't think i'd ever seen it tng
touched on this occasion there's a
couple of episodes where you know you
see the dark side of the the federation
um
but not really you know that the pegasus
episode a couple of others
um but in this it really we know we saw
what people are actually capable of when
we're threatened and when we're you know
we're backs against the wall sort of
thing and and what humanity's capable of
and it was i don't know it's more
realistic
than than maybe tng where's that you
know there was this utopia the golden
age of the federation and
and everything else and everything was
all lovely and fuzzy
you know
whereas this thing got a bit gritty
you know like uh you know
cisco is you know the real problem with
the federation is earth
you know because on earth it's a
paradise no one's hungry there's no
homelessness and everything but out here
you know at the ass in the federation
space
it's not earth
yeah
yeah exactly i mean how many missions
did garrett go on for for god's sake i
mean you know
i love the garrett character he was
fantastic and he was just such a
brilliant actor he's one of those actors
that he's he's he's phenomenal even when
he's acting like a complete
evil he's just great and i love that the
episodes where he's um because he's a
claustrophobic
genuinely brilliant acting fantastic
acting
acting skills i can't remember the act
i'm a schmutz i can't remember the
actor's name right off top ahead but the
other play garrick i think he was
probably the best actor
in the cast
he come across as a proper actor you see
him on stage or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean he yeah i
mean he was a very um
i mean he he remind me a lot of patrick
stewart having those you know
just i don't know screen presence or
something you know
yeah i mean i think the um the guy that
plays cisco is brilliant avery brooks
everybody
the guy that plays him dr bashir is a
really good actor as well actually to be
fair but they had a really good cast
for that show it did yeah yeah i mean
they all were you know went on to do
really cool things i mean um
last time i saw uh alexander sedig i
think the guy that that's the
the name of good play uh dr bashir he
was in an episode of foundation which is
on apple plus still haven't seen dude
it's the yeah oh there's a [ __ ] yeah all
all the first seasons episodes are up
it's a it's a brain bender
because here's the time to get them on
the subscription yeah yeah it's time to
get them on the subscription i need to
watch that serious jason remoted anyway
but anyway going off topic so i put a
poll on
last week here we go we've got 213 votes
and but the question was what is the
best star trek and then what really
inspired us to do this video was
actually after it'd been up two or three
days deep space nine was way ahead i
mean it was like it was d6 was like 40
of the votes or something but i mean
obviously obviously more votes came in
and it's evened out a little bit
and um so i'll give you the numbers the
original series 18 the next generation
was the winner with 36 just over a third
of the votes for you just 16 deep space
nine 21.9 uh 21 which i thought was
really interesting an enterprise nine
percent
is there anything that really surprises
you with those with those numbers yeah
you know it's um
every generation has a track i mean
there's you know there's so much
material out there
oh if you throw in the books and comic
books i mean there's
literally there's some but something for
damn near everybody to fan over you know
um
i mean that's why i love the tng so
that's my star trek that was this trick
when i was like 15 16 but you know so
that's mine right
and i think it's just a wealth of
material and deep storytelling is uh
i think that's why it has such a broad
audience is there's something for
everybody you know
depending on what kind of story style
you want you know
you may be i mean you may have kids that
are just you know
neck deep in prodigy
because it tells a wholly different side
of the
story can't talk about prodigy because
we haven't got it in the uk yet we're
not allowed it well we have prodigy and
tea
what does that tell you
yeah the americans are spoiled
actually we'll probably get prodigy on
um this new channel let's just come out
pluto that's where we're getting disco
haven't watched it robinson andrew
robinson's gotta play garrick ah he'd be
wrongly attacked good memory well done
um
the original serious thing right that's
got 18 of the votes
so that parade's pretty much steady
throughout the throughout the um
throughout the poll see there's a reason
why we're still making
the original series and everything
everything star trek does is compared to
the original series you know we've got
strange rules coming up
and
one of the things for that is they keep
saying it's going to merge it's going to
be the best of new trek right the best
of all trek you know we're going to get
back to you know like
i mean the whole title strange new world
comes straight from the opening bit of
yeah
i'm quite excited about it
i'm not even a bit
but we'll talk about the new track
in a little while because i've got some
quite strong opinions on it just to just
to clarify the new trick we're
discussing is the stuff from paramount
plus right everything jj abrams onwards
yeah
okay we're starting at jj the kelvin
timeline too yeah yeah so we'll talk
about everything from the after we went
on hiatus i'm referring to his new trick
and
do you think there's a reason why the
original series is basically still being
remade or just you know those characters
are refreshed i mean i'm even saying the
strange new worlds is is basically
rehashing an old story
again
is there a reason for it was it that
good was it that innovative was it that
different
uh in terms of innovation for
uh 1960s oh yeah it was that iterative
you know
see i suffered through we had two
channels
maybe three if the cloud cover wasn't
good wasn't that bad for west virginia
and you know it was soap opera the the
most radical thing on tv
before star trek came out was dark
shadows
oh yeah it was a soap opera
that you know and it was vampires and
things well it started as just a
typical
romance drama right a little bit of
gothic stuff feeded in but it was it was
going to be cancelled you know so the
creator said well let's just throw in
vampires and [ __ ] everybody see what
and you know then they had um
what's the actor's name jonathan freed i
think that was uh playing barnabas
and it was just lit
you know uh i remember my aunt's coming
home from college you know just we got
to watch dark shadows and my grandmother
loved it for whatever reason
and so that was it was and that was an
accidental sea change i mean it was just
the producer saying well let's just go
have fun you know throw in vampires
willie lomax he's got to die
why not
uh and
but that was it
you know there wasn't anything
really serious i i mean you know lost in
space
my favorite martian or not syrian sci-fi
flander the giants shows like that with
her
voyage to the bottom of the sea and that
was about it that wasn't right right
and i think those were
those in the same period
see that we roughly in the 60s early 70s
wasn't a thing
but we're talking roughly in the uk
we didn't really have darker shadows it
didn't it didn't really come over here
and those though all those tv shows
didn't really work didn't come over
until the 90s and they were shown on
like sunday morning tv right our sci-fi
was
thunderbirds
doctor who
and that was it
you know so
star trek again was think but when when
star wars came out obviously that was
such a massive
hit that that's sort of when
we sort of started getting popular
sci-fi
yeah giants i was a knight came out two
years after the original track
oh there you go
so same sort of thing i suppose with the
moon landings and all this sort of thing
it was
sci-fi was popular
you know it's like
well that was the early stages become
really popular so
i always said it really interesting when
the next generation came out that how
angry people were people seem to forget
how angry everybody was
when the next generation came out that
um this isn't star trek
uh it's it's it's peeing all over the
original
uh everyone hated it before it even
aired
and now everybody keeps going on about
this thing with woke and you know uh
we're looking at getting new stargate
and new things like the new shows and
everyone's just immediately it'll be
rubbish every reboot is always rubbish
um and you know i'm not you know this
this show is going to be terrible i'm
not watching it
everybody did that 30 years ago with the
next generation
and now we consider it
they didn't have the word they hadn't
invented the word woke yet in 1966
but you know the the um
the local clans groups hated it because
of you know a or any racial kiss
uh b
um
capitalism ultimately failed
you know so there there's that and so oh
it's a communist party the reds are over
here you know in hollywood they've taken
over the jews i mean there was hot and
cold running hatred over the original
trek in the 60s because my grandfather i
mean the thing with the with the
interracial kiss is that had to be
forced that's not what gene roddenberry
wanted to do he wanted to have them
kiss
and then the executive freaked out and
went no you will start a riot
we can't do that so they had that child
thing that forced them to kiss and
that's sort of like that made it okay
because i don't know yeah they don't
want to kiss each other they have to and
that was but they were still you know oh
there were still there were still
protests uh
my grandfather was so pissed off about
it that i couldn't watch track anymore
you know that is insane
he he he had his issues
really all grandparents yeah oh my god
jesus dude it's
a different generation mate is
completely different generation well you
know you might not have a different
generation but he was still on the the
the bad end of that of that i mean he
there there's people that grew up in
that generation that wasn't like him
he was one of those people and uh
so anyway that's a whole different and
that's a psychology job
but but still it was it was uh still
mayhem you know people i mean it was in
the paper it wasn't talked about in
church
even though his force didn't care they
touched lips
yeah
oh and then he's he's legally looking up
his eyes are open we all know that
a kiss with your eyes open isn't really
a kiss as well so you know
that's a almost check i always have one
eye open just make sure my wife's
actually got her eyes closed my kisser
just to make sure she's
not angry at me it's a thing honestly
but you're not convinced
i was thinking of the first episode of
the reboot of battlestar galactica
yeah you know
six comes in are you alive
and then she kisses the guy
and his eyes are open probably because
he's in terror you know and then he dies
of course
and never mind that was uh we've got to
do i'm going to do a video on the on the
the mini series about star galactica and
i am going to make the argument that
that is probably
some of the best sci-fi that's ever been
made that first this is i'm not i wasn't
a massive fan of the series it got a bit
as it went on it got a bit out of it but
um but that mini series
it's genuinely phenomenal i think that
goes up against anything else so one of
the common elements between battlestar
galactica and the
two version two
and uh
deep space nine
i think it's the reality and the shock
factor of it as well though i mean and
the and the layers to it that the scene
that made me sort of go this is
different
was when um the i'm sorry it's a long
time since watches i'm not gonna
remember the names but the tall blonde
um cylon and she's cooing the baby right
and she's sort of like oh isn't it
fragile and you see her the baby's
crying they hear it and the baby stops
crying right
uh how many tv series can you ever see
that
a child dies never mind a baby
in the first i mean i know it was done
for a shock factor but i mean it worked
and it told you a lot about what was
going on in the series
deep space nine obviously never went
quite that far
right but there were elements to that
show that make you sort of go oh this is
this is different
um you know um
and then it just yeah just the just the
reality of it i think was it well it's
not reality obviously because it's a
fantasy
but the the grounding in something that
we can um
that we can you know relate to
right
and what do you think
well the um
i think is because you know
they were created by the same guy
yeah well you know i mean you know the
the show runner for deep space nine he
spent you know the form and wrote most
of the episodes the same guy that
produced uh and wrote most of the
episodes for battlestar galactica
you know and
i think you could probably see that in
some of the battle scenes and things
yeah
the thing that stands out for me d space
nine as well was the battle scenes
which i'm in love i love a decent battle
scene that's right i love the movies
when they come along and it's why i
can't hate nemesis however much the film
isn't the greatest right because the
battle scene is great
and they normally let us down with the
battle scenes but in deep space nine
they didn't i mean and i i
watch an excelsior class starship blow
up i i love that as much as the next man
and that happened every three or four
minutes it was you know it was fantastic
um i've just done a video about how i
think the excelsior's the greatest star
fleet design it this because you know
it's on the front line for a century
sort of thing it is now
it's a great ship and it blows up
beautifully
like every five minutes
but you know it's
but yeah that i think that was the that
was the thing with that it's just that
the d space nine didn't have that fuzzy
star trek everything's brilliant
moments you know it actually had we're
actually
uh at risk of losing everything here
sort of thing and um
and in battlestar galacto obviously they
lose everything it's just survival it's
just stressfully trying to survive
you know it's just like can we just get
past today sort of thing
and again that's different that's not in
a lot of
you know a lot of sci-fi something
um
but anyway we'll get back to star trek
so yeah but so anyway you know uh my
idea about you know ronald moore you
know he he wrote a lot of the episodes
for uh
the uh next generation and he was neck
deep in deep space nine and um
there's a lot everything he writes tends
with the exception of caprica
has really done well there's this one
show called outlander it's kind of a
time traveling romance series that's
really good
and it's you know i guess it's about
here
yeah i mean i never really got into it
but yeah i guess it's kind of sci-fi in
a timely whimey kind of way
you know
but also you know he does this thing for
apple plus called for all mankind it's
like um
if um
the premise is what if the russians got
to the moon first how would that all
play out
and it's like an alternate history and
it is really engaging too um
so i think
the the the key factor here is
ronald moore doesn't get enough credit
for what he's done in episodic sci-fi
you know because
i mean the things we're talking about
and we're gushing over all had his
fingers in it you know the the creative
the writing
that's really true
um
all right if we get back to these this
this poll
16 for voyager that's pretty low
that's fair
i mean
all of these series suffered with
first series crappiness great um
you know so it's every single one even
the next generation first here is crap
um you know although they had had
moments in it though i would honestly
say conspiracy is one of the best star
trek episodes it's because i mean that
stands out um
voyager really until they encountered
the borg that show was boring as hell
deep space nine really until the defiant
comes into it it's it's not the most
interesting show in the world um
sixteen percent before you check
it was on what it shared
it was on at the same time
deep space nine was on for what three or
four years that's yes
overlap which was uncommon
well ds9 and tng overlapped for two or
three series as well didn't they nothing
really okay yeah yeah that's why there's
a there is an overlap episode isn't
there it's the dxd the first episode of
these was nine cards in it i think it's
only two seasons actually i think it's
just two years
ago
but yeah the first episode um the
enterprise visits deep space now yeah
they overlapped by one season oh one
season okay a voyager ended and then
enterprise
uh with jonathan archer it was it
started up in that same year but the
biggest overlap they've had is of course
deep space nine and voyager so i'm
wondering if
well i've only got enough room in my
plate for
one star trek thing this week
yeah
maybe i don't know
i think there's
i think like the final finale episodes
of all of these series
tng's finale episode was good you know
you know it was really good and it did
tie a lot of things together right the
deep space nine finale for me was
actually
two or three episodes before
the the last the finale episodes ties
everything up with the prophets and
stuff but it's actually quite i think
it's quite forgettable and it's not my
favorite part of that series
voyages finale was brilliant
voyages finale for me was the best two
you know it was the best finale of any
of the series they've ever done right it
was it tied it all up really nicely they
got home in a way that wasn't stupid
and it was entertaining obviously the
borg were in it and the ball grace and i
know so
i like that thing you know where the the
the the the portal opens you know all
this you know borg debris shoots out and
then here comes voyager yeah getting out
with it
like oh that's wrong
but there was lots of rumors at the time
that voyager wasn't going to make it
home
um and that was going to be the
cliffhanger sort of thing and then they
did
excuse me um you know i i just thought
it was phenomenal i think sixteen
percent of it and
the characters i i didn't i wasn't a big
fan of chicoto don't get me wrong eid if
chicote wasn't there i wouldn't have
cared at all it wouldn't have really
made any difference
janeway was a brilliant captain um and i
you know when she lost her temper
it was good
do not approach less caffeinated you
know oh yeah yeah i'll give that girl a
coffee and she's all right um seven of
nine is still one of my favorite
characters in any star trek um not just
because jerry ryan is astonishingly
stunning no no sorry it is because jerry
ryan's astonishingly stunning
um i i love her very very much and
there's the q squared episode when
junior q junior is comes on and he's
looking he's watching
of nine and he goes you know clicks his
fingers and her clothes disappear and he
goes she's just turned down and goes do
you think i'm gonna get embarrassed i
sort of think and i'm just like that is
apparently one of the most paused and
rewound bits of any star trek ever and
i'm like
yeah exactly
um
i'm doing a video soon about star trek
and um the queue
and that is one of the scenes that i
think tells you a lot about the queue is
when he's sort of like don't antagonize
the borg he's not bothered that janeway
was nearly you know assimilated he's
bothered that queue junior
was messing around with the borg again
and i'm like i think that tells you a
lot about the queue but anyway that's a
teaser for a future video i'll tell him
what those are just they know galanci
first you know he was the villain right
out of the gate farpoint station you
know
uh and um
and he was just right up uh you know
right right up a card's ass about it
you know and he's been
you know sprinkled in i don't know
i don't think he q ever the q ever
appear in a deep space nine episode
one
and it's the most forgettable episode
cisco bit slaps him at one point and
knocks him on his ass one card goes
the card never hit me
put the card i'm not the card
um but yeah
yeah it was enough the episode really
doesn't really tell you anything about
the queue it's a bit of an odd episode
really
um
but boys yeah he was in
three or four episodes of voyager and
actually the queue junior is actually
his son
it's his is his real lifestyle
yeah which i really liked yeah um so
that was always interesting someone's
going to tell me i'm wrong there but
it's definitely either it's definitely
his same second name anyway it's
delancey it's something to like
yeah and and and what's the chances of
that
yeah exactly no i'm pretty sure it's
done
i think they've actually he's actually
been in uh lower decks yes yes he's done
one episode of the load x as well but
that's not canon we're still gonna have
this argument
so
enterprise with nine percent
i'm surprised it's even that high
the question was what is the best star
trek
discovery at nine percent that's that's
ten percent of people virtually we're
going to say you know
there's a 213 votes
there's 20 or so people that voted think
enterprise is the best star trek that
it's better than d supposedly voyager
the next generation in the original
series
what's your thoughts on that
well you know
i wonder if it's like market penetration
you know uh discovery
i mean i think it's the it was the first
series that of star trek anything that
you couldn't get on dvd
yeah you know this enterprise mate not
discovery
enterprise got nine percent of votes oh
enterprise got nine percent and
surprised well i guess
i guess uh you know julian blaylock's
you know um costume can only go so far
yes
i like the mirror the mirror of this
ones oh having a shower you can see the
newest spike every time they have a
shower um or getting the the spore the
the spore jail
uv bath after they came off of the uh
klingon ship that was a trap between the
uh
the gaseous layers of some gas giant
they weren't subtle where they were
there no they knew their audience
basically looks like lubricant
and i think speaks of the general you
know uh star trek fan is a little bit
more intellectual than you know a
titillating a titillated you know 12
year old boy that's not the market
audience yeah yeah it still works
it worked to a degree i watched it
and then you've got the mirror verse
episodes when they've all got their
belly buttons out just for no reason
everyone yeah
that's how you knew i i just always
wanted them to paint little evil goatees
on them but for the women women belly
buttons out men evil goatees and that's
that's the only way to do it but
i know i think enterprise nine percent
is is
is really generous but i
i
i'm more angry at enterprise and it
frustrates me because it should have
been better for me it's a serious it
didn't really ever quite know what it
was
and um and it shows it lost its identity
um i always thought it would be a show
about how the federation
becomes to be you know how the
federation
becomes the federation
but it's not it's really in the series
about the temporal cold war
and
and who've never heard of that thing you
know yeah exactly but that's just like
how did that not turn up and it really
annoys me that the enterprise even was
called the enterprise because that is
just like that they just wanted to call
the ship the enterprise because
obviously that's the ship we know so
they call it um if we call it the nx
enterprise then we get around the fact
that nobody's ever mentioned this [ __ ]
before
right um
and that it's not in the models you know
where picard's got his models on the
thing of all the enterprises
um it's not there
that's okay
they should have just called it endeavor
or something or you know
anything else
yeah and there were so many things they
could have done differently and and you
know the actors i know they've
over the years well it could have been
better you know or yeah i could you know
we didn't know exactly what was going on
and um
and i think even some of the senior
writers were unhappy with the direction
uh what was the producer's name
biermann was he still involved at that
point
they weren't happy it was just changed
in the third series didn't it to another
chat but yeah yeah and it was just uh
yeah if it wasn't you know named
enterprise and they did stick
i mean there was little flakes of you
know the starting you know the the
antagonism
i think there's still lots of stories
you could have had with the antagonism
or the uh
overprotectiveness
of the vulcans you know the um
you know the the how you know why is uh
you know uh
mine melds
why is that verboten you know i mean
that was those are still great stories
we thought we found out a lot about you
know vulcan early culture
that was never mentioned anywhere else
we just it was we started off at one
point and that was how vulcan always was
except you know only time they mentioned
the past was you know when they
converted to logic never the
the bumpy road during that point and i
think all of that was missed opportunity
and um i think it was so well badly done
that i think it's gonna be a long time
before we see that kind of star trek
again yeah but there was so there were
some parts of it was so brilliantly done
and that's why it makes it so the
relationship between humanity and the
vulcans the first two episodes actually
i thought was stunned that beautifully
made and really set things up i didn't
like the whole cling on bits but right
broken bow was that the name of the
episode oh yeah
um you know so
but the relationship between the
humanity and vulcans i was just like
that's genius that's that's actually
what it would be like yeah i can see us
being like the vulcans in their logic
and let's just go home just let us out i
could see it perfectly done
well yeah
like the cooler as well
you had those little moments like uh
when first time the enterprise crew
hits an alien world you know and tripp
is i don't know he's in like the
concourse of some really dimly lit mall
and there's this mother suffocating her
son you know he gets all pissed off
about he doesn't know that the kid's
being weaned off of whatever atmosphere
he grew up in
of course
he sees it through humanizes being cruel
and unusual
you know and um
really clever and he gets [ __ ] slapped
by the uh by the local vulcan no dumbass
she's been
yeah stopped looking at everything for
human eyes yeah i mean yeah the growth
was good
we needed more of that and less of the
temporal cold war
you know more i want to see more of the
how did red alert come along and photon
torpedoes and all this sort of thing i
wanted to see more of that but
they missed an opportunity there and
that's what frustrated me and
the enterprise nx
second version with the um where they
were going to put an engineering section
in and it looked a bit a lot more like
um
a constitution class they were going to
bring that in for the fifth series
apparently and that frustrates me now
because it looks great yeah and if
you've ever seen it it looks amazing and
but it's beta cannon it's not real but
they should have done that at the end of
series four
they had the battle with the sphere
builders and the zindy and enterprise
limped home after getting its ass handed
to it you know it's heavily damaged
right that's when they should have done
the refit
yeah could have given the series a real
it would have been logical could have
given the series a kick up the ass it
needed um and you know i i think we
could have seen we could have seen a six
series
you know
looking back you know something
what
what could have been in terms of uh star
trek enterprise
what if it looked a lot like the expanse
you know that's right i mean it was it
was mostly you know uh enterprise was
mostly earth-centric
uh but there was a lot of um
i mean you know humanity had moved out a
little bit farther even with warp one
warp two ships or whatnot
um
i mean what about the you know what
about the belta loader what about those
guys you know
yeah
yeah those things we saw we only got
hints of loads of times that i wish we'd
seen more of like where the pilot had
come from when he was a boomer sort of
thing and then they never really
explained that they just sort of managed
to mention that a few times so you know
we were we were out there when without
warp and without gravity and without all
this sort of thing we never really got
to see any any of that really it was
very much centered on the enterprise i'd
have wanted to see a lot more about
starfleet and starfleet
growing pains and things never mind the
fact that there's
we don't actually see how the federation
came to be
it's all in the last three episodes we
sort of jumped from nothing to like oh
five years in the future and uh
everyone says i i've had arguments with
people about the last two episodes of
this of enterprise and i'm saying that i
voyaged the last two episodes for me are
the best someone is the best one right
enterprises last two episodes are the
worst it's it's not a good episode
as an end of series episode
just like you know the end of season
sorry episode it's quite good
to key up the next series i think it's
quite a good episode you know i really
like how it hark back to the pegasus
episode in tng i i quite liked the reich
a bit
um
but as a finale for the series it's
awful
it's really really bad
but they got cancelled but they've
already written it
and then they got cancelled so they just
reworked it a little bit to
make it work for what they had said okay
yeah and um
that was the last you know broadcast
television of uh star trek he kind of
gave a finale on it and you went to
hibernation until you know paramount
said well we got to figure out something
completely different and then we got
discovery
so yeah
enterprise ended bit of a failure sadly
and we then had like you said a hiatus
and then we had the jj abrams reboot
right
why do you think we have we have this
insistence
on on on prequels
basically discovery prequel stranger
worlds prequel i mean stranger worlds is
even before the original series why
can't we have
um
a series like picard
set in as if it was you know like 30
years after tng so why do we keep having
to have
bloody sea prequels
i i think
laziness
you know because if you if you know you
develop this body of work you know
the original series the next generation
there they meant they talk a lot about
the past
well oh here we talk about an episode
whatever of the original series let's do
that because we you know we're so out of
ideas
we can either a reboot star trek j.j
abrams or we can develop something that
we've already talked about that makes it
easy for us
you know and i think it's just laziness
to come up with new material
i think with discovery they did two
seasons as a prequel which still winds
me up but still this makes no sense they
have the most powerful ship we've
probably ever seen
in the federation but it's at the same
time just before the original series
no sense they changed they changed
everything they kicked cannon to death
um but then they've moved it and now
we're in the future
and i'm like and now i'm like oh that's
a good that would be interesting oh no
there's no dilithium oh god this is
going to be so boring it's just like you
know i i kind of like that because you
know
in terms of canon you know and they
alluded this sometimes you know you'll
see somebody you know in the the the
future
uh cast you know like the the admiral of
starfleet talk about something like it
was so far in the past like what what
were the details
yeah you know and um
you know it goes back to the there they
mentioned a little bit about picard and
on this uh i think it's episode four
season four of discovery
and kind of the way you take it could be
one way oh that may not have you know
went well for picard or could have been
another way i don't know but it was just
and they're kind of really fuzzy on all
the details so you can get by with
how did that go and just because
humanity has marched so far
yeah
i mean especially the the burn and the
collapse and the
the
the the way that happened as well i
suppose it would be maybe not as
important i mean they were at the brink
of complete
god you know the federation was nearly
gone
and that is the exciting thing about
disco the way they've done that is that
they could actually now do anything
yeah um and i love i haven't seen the
start as disco yet in their fourth
series um
i did get one interesting comment though
about discovery
and the guidance basically says is it
really sci-fi or is it
um fantasy
is it um more like star wars and like a
space opera than it is star trek
and i think he's got a really
interesting point because it is
the whole style
is is really not
star trek i mean everything with the
with the with the
klingon sorry in the in the very first
episode and that that space battle
it's not really very tricky
it's more
star wars-y
in its style
it reminds me of a line from firefly
you know uh wash is sitting at the
dinner table along with his wife and
he's discussing something and he says
god that's just like science fiction and
his wife leans over and said honey
you're living on us on a spaceship it's
one of the greatest lines you know it is
it's like yeah you live in a thing yeah
you live in a space
where is that line you know it's it
isn't yeah but i think the lines it's
it's science fiction is supposed to be
even though it's fiction it's supposed
to be based
on
science it's supposed to be based on
something you can relate to sort of
thing
discovery seems to have just gone away
from that it just seems to have gone
that's everything that you know like
let's ground it in some sort of
theoretical science you know the tng the
dyson sphere even warp and you know the
energy all of this was based on loosely
i suppose you could argue some sort of
react reality or at least theory if
something isn't you know there's a
science element to it
disco's just gone spore drive yeah
that'll do it yes
and and you know and but i mean the way
the klingons are they come across like
it is like a space opera you know just
sort of like it's just
something there's no um
i think that the science part of it
might may be gone and that's not
necessarily a bad thing um
because you know and and i think i think
that is a discussion i just thought it
was a really interesting comment to make
and as this chap actually goes on to say
he loves it he thinks it's great
um but it is a space opera now it's not
science fiction anymore
and i think he's got a really
interesting point i think picard
as well we'll talk about the card in a
minute but i think that's similar
um
but we'll talk about the the talk about
the poll i did so i want to say right so
how does the original or the classic
star trek
um compare to
jj abrams disco card everything else so
i i think the answers are really good
though so so first of all it's totally
different you can't compare them it's
like it's like chalk and cheese sort of
thing it's not fair to compare them at
all
that's 26 percent a quarter of people
basically agree with that um
33 a third of people the biggest chunk
of people when you can't compare them
because the new stuff isn't particularly
good isn't very good
and then and no i liked i leaned towards
that a little bit as well but i think so
26 of people said it's different but
it's still good
um and then uh 15 people said it's a
modern take on star trek so yeah again
maybe it's a bit different but it's
brilliant they love it it's still star
trek star trek star trek at the end of
the day
freaking love it um i i'm not
the massive fan of new star trek don't
get me wrong i'm a trekkie i'll still
watch it
um but sometimes i watch it and i am
there i you know i have to
so that i i'm always put putting up
proof parts of it
and i love the jj abrams movies i
thought they were great movies i really
enjoyed them i don't really consider
them star trek
i think they're more like just like a
good sci-fi movie you could you could
remove if you changed the ship design
well they did change the ship design
every film is horrendous
um but if you could you could check you
could call that the hms
reliant or something and change all the
character names let's not call it star
trek it'd be a good film but it wouldn't
be star trek
um right the i really set the the kelvin
timeline you know the stuff that jj
abrams put out well i thought
in terms of content was like you said i
mean i think is like some of the weakest
you know i frankly i would have rather
seen and i'd rather see another stab at
something like enterprise and see you
know some of the abroad movies because
they seem like you know oh we're doing
kobayashi maru
again
yeah it's like oh dude is there some
other thing in starfleet training other
than kobayashi maroon and these guys
are are they studying for you know day
into and sometimes at some point in time
the students are going to let it leak oh
that's a [ __ ] class
you know i mean
they're always so surprised don't they i
can't win i can't win that's the point
of it yeah it's just you know at some
point someone's i mean [ __ ] i mean they
you know
uh you know bones talks about it you
know incessantly about how kirk you know
re-did it
so it can't be a secret and in it it's
just
it just it's just like he said i think
it's another star trek movie
you know uh i i think you know picking a
uh cumberbox is like you know khan
noonie and sing
he didn't look like a car noonian sing
to me
on paper that was genius on paper
benedict cumberbatch's card i was like
yeah
in the actual movie it didn't quite work
he actually overdid it yeah hearing it
all the wrong times it's just like
no did not right where it goes
you're my real name's god
we knew that
i knew that half an hour ago
yesterday um yeah so
don't forget though i love the film
um i just it's just not
star trek
um but but you know i love the film and
and you know i like i love a lens flare
as much as the next month so you know um
and you know it's brilliant i hate that
they basically seem to make the
enterprise hydroelectric that really
annoyed me um they seemed to they have
one warp core but then you see um like
eight jump out um you see a black hole
being used as a as a time traveling
transportation device and i'm like
stephen hawking you'd be spinning in his
grave
um you know it's just like
loads of bits of that film made no sense
um a star blew up
and unless it's the romulan star which
they don't ever actually say but unless
it's the romulan star blowing up how the
hell did it destroy the romulan home
world
or how the hell did it do it so that but
they didn't see it coming do you know
how fast space not there if it's a
different star went supernova they would
have
many years advanced notice before the
shock wave hit romulus but we'll ignore
that but actually i think they hinted
that picard because they do try to
actually get everybody off romulus and
um and they have time to actually build
a fleet of ships to go and save as many
people as possible until the android so
so so maybe that's not a fair point but
um you know there's just loads of bits
in that film as a trekkie i'm going
sort of thing but as and just enjoying a
movie that's a good movie well yeah in
were you know in in terms of
you know the abram stuff you know
especially you know
you know beyond and in the darkness
where did that really take us
in terms of
nothing really just i mean
i pulled this one episode one of my
favorites of the original series
the devil in the dark
oh you'll have to remind me okay devil
and dark there's these miners uh that
on this planet
uh there's all their uh they can't make
their shipments to uh starfleet or to
federation
and
enterprise is sent in to get them back
on track
you know kirk goes down it turns out and
spock there's all these little shells
around and but there's these men are
being killed by something and it turns
out there's a hort a creature a silicon
based life form called a horta
that has thousands of these eggs and
she's protecting the brood
but he's injured and uh so uh bones is
sent down with some
cement and and
heals the hoarder
i tell you what jim i think i can cure
anything
you know and so
that subject especially in the 60s
broached all sorts of things you know uh
cooperation between species
silicon based life forms i mean i'm i'm
trying to think of what episode of i
dream of genie
you know had silicon based life forms on
at that point
you know and that really
took that idea further
you know and so with khan we get he's
genetically modified
okay
uh he he he can jump far long distances
okay okay
that was done in dune
yeah yeah it's we're you know trek is
known for where it takes us like holy
[ __ ] how why didn't we think of that
and that's where you know when it really
catches you at least good sci-fi not
just necessarily in
star trek but any really good sci-fi
it expands your mind to where you want
you have an emotional reaction holy [ __ ]
that's amazing like um
is it larry niven ring world
oh yeah yeah of a of a circle
you know just you know around the star
you know and think of how much land
that would open up for you i mean there
would be no overcrowding i mean you do
there would be lots of fornicating that
have that to over
well infinite power infinite energy
and
it says it's those holy hell moments
it's like oh my god that is insanely
cool
yeah i just don't get you know from
there wasn't that in yeah there wasn't
that in the in the films the only the
only bit that i think
i liked is we we found out why bones is
called bones you know she's got divorced
says she took everything but my bones
other than that
she got the moon in the divorce yeah
there was there was there's not a great
deal in
that in that in that in in those three
films that really pushed it and we
learned anything really
and i think strange new worlds will be
more interesting from that point of view
i think we'll learn a lot from that i do
wonder if that could morph into
a new
original an actual reboot of the
original series that we will actually
see kirk captain the enterprise at some
point again
um i i just have a suspicion that might
be where that goes but we'll see well i
mean one of my all-time hated
star trek things was star trek beyond
it's not a good film it was you know
it just oh god you know
oh let's take the crash landed starship
right and let's get that thing flying
again
you know
it was not like you know star trek
prodigy where the ship was in decent
shape
this was i mean it was just beat all the
i mean it just
it was just nothing you know it was just
i mean the actors it's not their fault i
mean they they get you know script and a
bunch of money
and they'd do their best but i just
don't think the story was there and it
was just like oh beyond let's just i
don't know let's watch a rerun of
seinfeld
yeah i mean but it was there's lots of
things in that film that made no sense i
mean like the in the crystal stuff that
comes at the back of the motorbike that
he charged around on and it's like that
was just done for a like a stunt
it was not done for a reason they just
did they just wanted to do that as we
wanted to make an action film make no
sense the the yeah the franklin is it
that's fine but i mean
it's albert's character
don't care by the end so like whatever
beautifully done i looked at the star
base
it's stupid
it's a
you actually think about that from a um
a design point of view it's the
stupidest design in the world it makes
no sense yeah yeah oh yeah let's not get
into the civic in in mechanical
engineering problems of that whole thing
it was like this comes in and goes
through the tunnel thing i like looked
beautiful but like again my tricky side
goes what a load of [ __ ]
i mean that makes no sense they could
have taken that budget and made you know
mad max four you know you know and
throwing tina turner you know under the
thunderdrum and it meant a better movie
because that's essentially what it was
but every instead of starfleet uniformed
you know put them in their best amber
crombie and fitch with leather and some
acid chaps much better movie
you know the best bit of that film um
other than i mean some of the some of
the visual effects is stunning i love
the bit where the enterprise is is
flying along and ever and all the little
things that the swarm ships are blowing
up for the music's playing looked great
my tricky side goes with a load of crap
but look great the best bit of that film
was when they made zulu gay
and i love that there's a little as a
little nod to the um to the original
actor sort of thing um who fought for
gay rights his whole life
yeah i i liked that bit and that stood
out in the movie for me as the bit like
because that was that actually was worth
the rest of the film
but that's a reason why we haven't had
another jj abrams movie
since
and we may not get one so there's still
normally known about whether to do one
or not aren't they but
yeah you know i think uh
i don't know with what he did with the
trek
and what he did with uh star wars the
last three chapters yeah star wars in
general
you know give it to you know i think
star wars is in the better hands of
happy
yeah yeah you know
um yeah well i mean
i mean you know like mandalorian they
had their [ __ ] tight
if we could just get a mandalorian
quality story out of the star trek
universe
i think it'd be awesome
something
it needs the best show runner though
mandalorian's got a great show runner
you know he's like he knows his stuff
who is actually a consultant his name's
got out my head which is really annoying
i can picture him and but he's actually
a consultant on orville that you aren't
the massive huge fan of what i love it's
okay i mean the first episode the guy
ejaculates out of his face what's not to
love
exactly and um yeah i i do question some
of the humor i think it's is it is it a
comedy or is it a sci-fi i'd question
that sometimes i couldn't tell where
people don't like it if you don't like
his sense of humor you're not gonna like
the show
um but i mean um i think it's actually
the best star trek on telly
it's the orville i think it's better
than anything else but let's talk about
disco and
so
discovery you're wrong go ahead sorry
i know i'm going to say that i
i don't again i don't
i never like the premise
i don't like the style
i don't like what they did to the
klingons i don't like that they kick the
cack out of um cannon
but i actually do quite like the show
and um i think you've always got the
first series is always crap so we can
swipe out the first series we can ignore
it every first series of star trek is
awful
or at least it gets better right um
the second series i've not actually
watched all of i got bored but the third
series was great i really enjoyed it
the the the thing i liked about the the
first um
season was lorca
you know the the the captain's not the
captain the one from the mirror universe
i mean yeah yeah that was just you know
you think he's got psychological
problems but no he's just an [ __ ] and
the way it was played i mean you know
just exceptional way he played that like
he'd answer the door he's got a gun
behind his back
it's just i i really liked it for tho
those uh points you know yeah i think
there has been some really really good
bits i'd agree with you lorca's great um
actually fair if they took out the spore
drive out of discovery i think would
have been a lot better i think that was
that was their uh temporal cold war
mistake yeah temporal cold war and
enterprise spore driving in discovery
they should have took that out well you
know i i i can't
i'm gonna have to divert here there's uh
um
uh
so i there's a lot of documentaries that
came on um last couple years over uh
mushrooms
not magic mushrooms just the
um
mushrooms and fungi the kingdom of fungi
and that [ __ ] is so amazing you know
mycelium and how in my cilia and how it
just envelops most of the topsoil of
earth and kind of really its own little
organism and it's just this and i can
say oh
i can see where that somewhere there was
a biology student in the writers room
that pitched that and said well now
i said oh we know now that i've seen
like i don't know 10 straight hours of
mycelium documentaries
i can kind of see that now
at the end
i mean just like the thing we tried
what's the what's the
thing called that they plug into the
oh it's going to annoy me somebody in
the comments will tell me the um the
creature
yeah but that's a really great creature
yeah that that's that's a real microbial
creature on it that can survive
radiation and then you know all sorts
um
they think they could even spread among
the uni you know the galaxies because
they found spores of this thing that are
five million years old and then when
they warmed them up they hatched you
know it's just like this is an
incredible tardigrade has survived
tardigrades have survived uh five
extinction level events just here on
earth
and they can live in the vacuum of space
it's it's the most
i mean hell i i i even follow an account
on my on my twitter that was the daily
tardigrade i mean it's just
and it's insane little critter
and if it was the short tracks
or uh discovery
the
the girl you know very young michael uh
has a stuffed tardigrade
that's a stuffy
and it's just oh that's so adorable no i
want one
but yeah so i mean i was very i thought
the same way i felt the same way as you
know i really yeah it's just and then
like oh i saw all the mycelium yeah
i do like that yeah they based that on
some sort of science which i did like
and then went
with it unlike jj abrams which was
you know romulan miner
really mm-hmm
yeah exactly
just things like how massive the
enterprise is the enterprise is much
bigger than the enterprise e
because jb abrams went let's make it
bigger there's no reason for it
he just went we'll make it bigger yeah
we're gonna this is gonna be an imax
let's make it bigger now the engines
they look too sensible and usually they
come stupid looking it's just everything
about that ship is like let's create
some flappy things why
i just think it'll look nice
can somebody punch jj abrams in the face
please yeah like stop him ruining my
show
because it's just all style over
substance
yeah exactly that that is perfect saying
actually putting that
can you say the same thing about
discovery though because it's a
beautiful show you know the battle
between the federation and the klingons
in the in the first i think it was the
second episode of discovery is stunning
looking i mean yeah it's great
um the way the klingon ship goes into
the admiral ship and it's just
is stunning
but um
it's still i mean i still think it's
quite forgettable because i don't think
there was a great deal of substance to
it
it was it's more visually nice than
maybe
yeah you know the um
one of the
one i think one of the best characters
that has been developed in the whole
uh streaming star trek universe not the
kelvin line
was giorgio
i love the georgio character michelle yo
is stunning i love her and everything
yeah and you know where in the last
episode how they wind up how they
finished and then once they finish how
they
uh exit that character from that series
you know is is the guardian i was like i
was like who is this guy with the bowler
hat who i mean he's reading it right
right what the [ __ ] is going on
then he turned out to be the guardian
and go oh my it was like one of those oh
my god
we got back to sci-fi
yep you know
and yeah that's one of my favorite
episodes in a long long time of star
trek yeah yeah yeah and uh you know
philippa georgia the way they exited her
from that series
it was
i don't think it was like okay
it was one of those things we're just
talking about earlier that they've run
out of ideas so let's go milk an earlier
episode
i think
i don't think it was that i think this
was generally something
telling a little bit more about the
guardian
and
and and give and give a good send-off
for for uh georgio yeah does that make
any sense
because it goes back to one of the best
or one of the most memorable original
series episodes right um it gives us
more it but we've learned something from
it it's like he's talking about the jj
abrams movies
they don't really add anything to star
trek
that episode does that i mean discovery
does i mean however much you i know they
kick the crap out of cannon them times
and that is annoying right but but they
do episodes like that and you're going
that's what star trek should be
that adds something to the add something
to the genre it it you know it just adds
something to like so we learned
something more about the guardian and it
was no i i love that and um i
when it's done right
um
bringing back something like that and
bring about like the guardian and doing
something like that when it's done right
it's fantastic yeah um
yeah so
there's not fans of discovery people
either love or hate discovery um but um
you know
i
it's growing on me
like uh like a spore it's good
in terms of
television history i mean when um
uh captain kirk in the original series
said let's just get the hell out of here
one of the very first times in at least
in america that the word hell was used
in prime time
and that's what sci-fi should do to be
fair it should push the boundaries a
little bit
um well i think that's a good time to
talk to will mention woke and woke tv
and that's one of the things that people
do get angry about discovering they say
it's too woke
um and 50 of the characters are gay or
transgender or
you know i mean people have even talked
about how
michael has got a boy's name i'm like
what's that have to do with anything um
it's you know but
is one of the reasons why some people
hate discovery though is because it's a
little bit too
politically correct and
somebody cries every five minutes in
that damn show i mean
i mean there's a show i like and it's
growing on me right so so the whole
thing is like michael uh what kind of
crazy you know name is that for a girl
well nostradamus's first name was
michelle
yeah
it really doesn't matter
i mean you know
just just how rainbow flag was that and
this and what
no it's just
guys get over it it's like you know it's
how many italian
years in the future and you can't have a
girl name i mean you know
anyway um it's irrelevant isn't it it's
completely irrelevant
people get upset about it that [ __ ]
irrelevant but
you know sci-fi you know pushing those
boundaries it it's not that
broadcast tv at least here in united
states broadcast television
lacked wokeness
the it wasn't the sci-fi writers that
lacked wokeness
it was the presidents of the uh channel
presidents of the network
you know i mean it's like i remember i
had a relative that blamed gayness or no
or she blamed oral sex on uh dr ruth
well if it wasn't for dr ruth talking
about oral sex there'd be no oral sex
have you ever seen any greco roman greco
art oh my god you know yeah they weren't
going to like monkeys i mean they put it
in the mosine they put you know acts of
oral sex depictions of it in the tiles
at the market right beside oh buy this
fish you know broth
it's not that it wasn't in science
fiction it's uh the
[Music]
the powers that be in broadcast networks
or publishing companies
wouldn't publish it
yeah i mean you know i mean if um
it reminds me of if people really knew
how much witchcraft was in the bible
would it be a bestseller today what if
you just took the bits of the bible
that included witchcraft in just a
separate you know volume the which
stories the holy bible
i mean part cakes
but it's just i think society's
self-censorship
that it doesn't cause wokeness it cause
it causes bigotry
yeah and i mean because there's i mean i
remember reading a site a star trek
novel i'm blanking on the title because
it was a long time mid 80s maybe
it's where uh the enterprise cr the
the original enterprise crew
runs into this planet where the um
sentient beings or cats
right
and they can't stop
looking at uhura
they don't understand why and
her is wondering starting to feel a
little bit you know put out so she later
asked why is everybody
uh staring at me and they and um
they don't know so they say eventually
down the story uh they asked she just
goes and asked them i said well
where are your
children well what do you mean my
children
your memories they're engorged why
aren't you feeding your children they
think that yuhura
is is mistreating her children just
because her breasts are whatever size
you know and can you imagine getting
that on 60s tv
no yeah and this is what america was
like
40 50 years old i guess yeah so but
something is a good sci-fi it should be
i mean i i hate the term work i hate i
don't enjoy the world um it's sci-fi to
me has always been best this way and
sci-fi writers will write about what's
important to them and then it's a social
commentary they're talking about what's
important or what's what the problems
are in society and i know term like
gender and stuff is a massive problem
for the kids
for the younger generation at the moment
i work in psychology
um as a job
and it is a big problem there's a lot of
research going through because our kids
are really struggling with it not all of
them obviously but it's a big problem
gender all of a sudden isn't like
as
fixed as it used to be
and people are trying to figure out what
that means and i was just trying to get
the reds around it and
all i've seen i love sci-fi is a
commentary on that and a commentary on
you know
the problems in society and it's still a
lot about race as well there's a lot
about race in star trek
um you know there's
like all good sci-fi you can look at it
on its surface it's just entertainment
and just watch it or you can enjoy the
that there are layers to it there are
meanings to these things
and you know there's a commentary on
politics
racism all the other isms right
and there's you know and there's just
episodes sometimes when just we just
want to be the [ __ ] out of somebody and
you know it's just an action
story and you know exactly
that's why i love it but okay
fine
i'm trying to
make sure i've got yeah
album
frederick poll gateway novel yeah in
1977
um frederick pohl
p-o-h-l wrote a novel called gateway and
there's a
very popular whole series of books i
don't know if you remember it or not uh
and it is talking about i mean
i re-read it recently
last year during coven
and it was like oh my god
in 1977 he's kind of describing the
american medical system
yeah you know with insurance and blue
cross and blue cross plus
it's like you know we [ __ ] about you
know health care is a right and or how
health care should not be a right in
america
and it's just like here's this guy from
1977 that nailed it
you know and is is also a treatment in
poverty and all this other stuff
i mean was he woke in 1977
i mean those are kind of woke topics you
know housing has a right health care as
a right i was thinking when people think
that like sort of the environment or
overpopulation is something people have
only been worried about the last decade
you can watch sci-fi and things like
this from um what was it the the one
with oh i've forgotten a name everyone's
um
exterminated at the age of 30.
so they they've got logan
logan's run that is talking about
environmental issues and
overpopulation and resources and all
these things that were a bit like oh god
this might be all of a sudden this is a
problem
um
50 years ago
you know we knew this was a problem 50
years ago it's just that we've ignored
it for through the reagan years or
whatever and through the prosperous
years of the 80s and 90s and now all of
a sudden you know it's becoming a thing
but sci-fi has always done that a good
sci-fi should do that and sometimes
sci-fi is just entertainment there's no
layers to it there's just like aliens
cool let's go kill them um but sometimes
there's a reason for it you know that
that's the best thing and don't get me
wrong it can be done badly and it can be
done well
sometimes discovery's done it well
sometimes it's done it badly yeah
picard
before we before we say good i say
because he's french
um if that's how you say i don't really
know me french um
i really enjoyed picard until the last
episode
and for me the last episode was just a
massive pile of burning horse manure
from pretty much beginning to end it was
just
bad and i will tell you well i mean i'm
quite happy to tell you why but what
what do you think about picard and
how do you think again it sort of like
as a
as a continuation of tng in a way
the only star trek we've got in
contemporary time that would be you know
like in the same time frame what do you
what do you think of it
okay so i i love picard up until kind of
the end i liked where
data just wanted the right to die
you know
uh which touches on all sorts of things
you know that's in it's that's been in
public conversation since
you know was doing physician-assisted
suicides
and uh i thought that was a really good
storyline i thought you know the whole
thing of um
the romulans or secret romulan uh
group is you know harvesting
um
illegal
borg tech i thought that was really cool
but the whole thing with the
the
the um
the sin the the the synthetic society
gone wrong
that was just
another song
oh yeah and sake
yeah it is
in that family is about that deep they
all look identical it's weird
you gotta get on episode season four of
um
uh discovering there's this little slice
in there and it's just
but yeah i just thought it was
you spent nine episodes getting to here
turn the most annoying bit for me you
know the the terrible
universe destroying bad guy that the
romulans were all so terrified of and
that the
the android society brought through with
their you know oh we're going to bring
it through and then that portal opens
you're thinking oh god this is going to
be terrifying and then just some stupid
little tentacles going
how
who thought that was a good idea
somebody almost got the device to go
born i think as a young kid
there's some tentacles
um it's just stupid um and obviously as
a trekkie i love the starships and
things i love the technical stuff the
starships i read the technical manual
for the you know um the enterprise like
religiously i'm like
you know that i remember watching them a
video and it did really really well on
some another youtube channel which i'm
not going to advertise
track culture that's really really good
and but they said oh my god there were
dolphins on the enterprise and i'm like
yeah i know because i read the technical
manual when i was like 10.
and it's just like i thought it was
weird at the time but you know
um
but so i love the starships the
starships at the federation because the
federation were completely missing
throughout that entire series right we
never see the federation at all
and then we see them at the end and all
those ships were coming in riker on the
bridge going i got the baddest whatever
you know the you know the toughest
starship and i got a whole fleet of them
he's got they're all like you starship
he's got the [ __ ] you starship
definitely and it's crap
it's ugly
um it's got a weird and for some reason
the shuttle bay at the front is wider
than the entire it would actually be
wider than the original enterprise
it's enormous
right randomly it's ugly the cgi was
really bad but i think that was because
they
rewrote the end because i think somebody
went you know what the federation
actually aren't in picard at all i think
they should probably turn up at the end
and and so they rewrote the end i think
but so the cgi is just terrible
all the ships are exactly the same which
annoys me when is that as i've been in
the federation well you know the the the
there is a way for
it to actually been worse and let me
tell you how
for the last episode of picard
instead of the federation and riker you
know coming in
you know to save the day
if it was only the zindy
okay
i want to i would say there would have
been you know
the the the insectoids
on the microphone and you get some kind
of crazy translation that only you know
i don't know sun can decipher oh i think
he said happy birthday you know
something i mean if you want to make it
shittier i think we can bring in the
zindy to save that oh you know we could
have made it worse yes
and that could have been in the tentacle
thing it could have been i don't know a
long lost species of the zindy before
the avians ever got it we see
[Laughter]
dies and they turn it into an android
and i was like god it's just like
you put a drunk person in charge of this
so
do you mind if i actually talk about the
spoiler from
discovery about the picard thing go on
then you're going to make me angry
because i'm not seeing it yet but so
there's this throwaway lying
and this goes back to uh we were talking
about you know in um season four
discovery they're in the advanced
timeline and there's a lot a lot of
history is just kind of fuzzy
and they kind of kind of maybe one way
you could look at it is they insinuate
that
uh picard's transitioning
to
uh you know a synthetic body
may have gone wrong
it would have tried a lot you know in
the past but
yeah it went it stopped after it didn't
go very well with what was it it was
that some admiral's name picarp card i
think it was
you know and because they're fixing up a
new body for somebody else and uh okay
so that's a spoiler something's gonna
come into the car series
yeah you could take it one way where
something really shitty happened to
picard or just you know it was just uh
dead end technology i don't know it
didn't work didn't work
i actually think i i think disco and
picard series 2
might be connected quite a lot though so
i think there's there's stuff with the
broken time and there's something about
i know q is in this series
and um
yes
i i wonder whether they're going to do
something with the burn
then there's going to be some sort of
connection there but
but i mean there's
it feels to me like disco is going to
it's going to be connected to a few of
you the series a little bit more that
we're going to get little things um
even with the steve's face
i'm just going to i just get the hints
that
we're going to get little comments like
that throughout discovery but we'll see
yes um but picard series 2 is
interesting for me because it's just the
whole thing with the queue the queue
fascinate me and
i wonder if we're actually going to find
out why
the queue
put humanity on trial
and is there going to be a an answer to
that because we never really found out
why are they picking on humanity um
surely if they're going to talk about
somebody being brutal and whether they
deserve to exist in the universe the
klingons are only around the corner
they're quite brutal and the romulans
are vicious as well i mean at least you
could say the klingons of violent
because of honor and stuff the romulans
are just violent
and they're you know they're there's
quite a sadistic people in a way yeah
you know so
um
so yeah and
why would he put humanity on things but
anyway that's
lots of theories
actually i've missed you
exactly yeah i love that and he's going
to appear as an old man because they're
going to have to do that she'll like say
oh you know i've seen it i haven't you
got old picard and
then he appears as an old man himself
but um i'd i just love
queue and that's going to be my next
couple of episodes on sidetrack again
because i'm looking at the queue
and i've got a few theories
was that was this the uh was the queue
in the
original series there's that question
um
trellone
trellani trelani i'm actually talking
about that because one of the questions
i have is the queue biological
is he has his superpowers sort of
evolved or is he or is it based on
technology
if treylan or trelani was
q which he looks like a queue in almost
every way
then they're technology based
so all of a sudden it may be why the
queue are so concerned about the borg
makes sense
and you know these things about don't
provoke the borg right because they're
obviously a species out of time per
chaps cue that they can jump forward to
backwards in time so maybe the q are
interested in humanity because of what
humanity has become become but they're
also fearful of the borg because of what
the bulk can become
what was the episode in uh original
series that um
it was the roman greco god
that oh yes it comes and pinches the
enterprise in a big giant house
it has a lot of bore i'm not born jesus
a lot of q type
sensibilities and powers and there's uh
there's a whole
argument there like was he q and just
not q or is he was he a mentally ill q
because he didn't didn't identify as q
every other q we've met oh hey q hi q
how are you doing oh i'm doing quite
well they call each other q they
identify yeah this but what if this was
a mentally ill cue
well we see that in voyager episodes
when the one wants to commit suicide and
stuff or it could also be an earlier
version of the kick
as well because again this is a species
out of time once they evolve and they
get up to that point
they can sort of go anywhere in time and
see everything and you know anything um
maybe this was we actually are seeing a
cue before they quite reach that level
right so very powerful but not maybe
quite continuum sort of level
so somewhere on the ladder yeah
maybe maybe that's what we're seeing i
think maybe the same with trelane that
we're seeing it's maybe a slightly
earlier version of the queue
and
but yeah but don't say i it makes more
sense to me if the queue are
technologically based you know there's
an articy clark saying isn't there you
know that um
any sort of um sufficiently advanced
technology would appear to be magic to
anybody else something and i think
that's right and that would make sense
why the cure is clicking fingers and
waving hands as well like they have to
sort of like
do something to trigger the
power or whatever but
yeah that episode we're talking about is
the squire of gothos
squire of gothos
i literally watched it
yesterday
because i'm researching for these q
episodes so that's why i'm i'm getting
ready for that so that'll be in the next
couple of weeks people
right so we're going to answer the
question then
we well we've said deep space nine for
us is probably the best star trek
how does that compare to what we've got
now do you do you think
it's it's as good as
you know a modern version a modern take
on what we've got but it's as good as
anything we've seen before or is it a
pale comparison
of star trek
i i think the you know the the 10
episode series that uh paramount is
pumping out i think they're good
i think they're good
but
you know when when we look back at uh
uh deep space nine we're looking at all
the seasons of deep space nine as a
completed
beginning to end the story
yeah and we don't have we don't know
what the end of discovery is you know is
there something that's going to explain
all this
you know
and and you know they're trying to do a
lot of things in just 10 episodes
how many episodes was in uh just deep
space nine is over they only do 24 26
episodes yeah
they're not always quite the same as
sometimes there's 24 sometimes 26. yeah
it depends on if there's a writer's
strike that year you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah true i just don't i i honestly
think they're just i don't think you
could compare them
i think they're very different
yeah
i think they're all so different you
really can't compare them yeah because
that's where i'm leaning it's it's a
very it's a different generation it's a
different the way tv is presented now is
very different like you said
it's that's the perfect way of pointing
actually it's like streaming star trek
versus
um network star trek sort of thing
um 10 episodes very different again the
budget is insanely different and the use
of special effects is different
and even though as a whole
i'm not a massive fan of discovery in
parts it's been brilliant
it's been so good in bits
and the whole thing would like you say
like michelle yo's character um i've
loved
the mirror universe episodes brilliant
um bits of it i hate but bits of i just
adore and i am looking forward to
starting to watch the new series and
deep space nine had 176 episodes so
there's a lot of story you can tell
in 176 episodes that
no
of the no none of the streaming uh
uh they're never gonna get how do they
know i'll never get that 100 they've got
to knock every episode out of the park
really there whereas in d space 9 tng
voyager even there was ups and downs
episodes that were really nothing
episodes but we forget them because
there were so many episodes
um you know there's some bad tng
episodes there were some even epis
series seven they went mental with some
of those episodes
they just sort of threw everything at it
and you know but overall
it's the characters that we remember
isn't it and i do wonder if we're going
to remember any of these characters from
um from from discovery
i can't see michael burnham being
remembered in 10 years time as a great
star trek character whereas
cisco
others o'brien even will be remembered
and data and you know picard and
all these characters seven of nine jane
like all these big characters will be
remembered
i think if anyone's only me
at least in my mind
uh one of the more memorable characters
from discovery
would be of course lorca
and saroo
is a character i really
ponder a lot about i really think about
you know i feel sorry for the actor
poor sod
the shoes and the things and the makeup
oh man the makeup's gonna be brutal
yeah it's gonna be
but there's something about you know the
[Music]
how sorew began
you know as just
you know sentient kelp
and then he met philippa giorgio
you know and she whisked him off the
planet off his home world disrupted his
life
but it was it was um
i mean that was really a science fiction
moment i mean it was like
what happens when you whisk somebody
away from their home when they're
they've already seen
ships from another world they already
know all of these things
but they're just out of sorts with their
community
yeah you know and it's just like that
was really good and so i think you know
saroo as a character
i mean we know more about michael
burnham you know there's interesting
bits there with her and um sarak but
i don't know i think there's a lot to
love about um
mr saroo
i think suru is a really lovable kind
and i think like you say georgia is the
character for me that
has been brilliant but michael burnham
was supposed to be the uh the lead and
she's no captain kirk put it that way as
a character
likeable actress but that's about it but
anyway right that will do a sensor thank
you so much for that and we are going to
be back in the next week or two doing
another live video hopefully with a
couple of other friends which we're
going to actually pick
our favorite episodes from every star
trek
the next generation series so a favorite
episode from each series and we might
throw a little cup a couple little curve
balls in there as well as the the the
episodes that make you want to
put your eye finger in your eyeball and
just say oh
no
you're laughing
mikey is going to be joining us and i i
am telling you now i know which episode
he's going to pick because i'm psychic
oh so i i i guarantee you i'm hoping
he's not watching because he'll it'll
spur it but okay let's see how good your
psychism is which is my
favorite as i say deep space nine
episode
um
oh i've got what it's called in the pale
moonlight
it's gotta be in the pale moonlight it's
by miles the best episode
go on then you tell me what is your
favorite detective
it's where uh
cork
leads a band of
friendly malcontents against the
dominion to rescue their mother
all hooked up with some sort of
neurological thing and blank you know
burned through his cerebral cortex and
just
yeah what a classic episode but when we
say what is your what is the episode you
hate most of any tng episode i'm telling
you mikey will immediately go
when um beverly crusher bonks a ghost
that he will say that immediately
he will i i promise you but anyway that
is for another week hopefully next week
if not hopefully the week after but
we'll it depends on people's
availability but that will be us so
stormy thank you so much for joining um
very welcome sir thank you for having me
if you have not i had a look at uh
cy works
not where i am sidetrack sounds like
you're like um geeky brother
and like him sci works i work for living
sidetrek
hey you know just uploaded the last of
the lost uh lecture series for carl
sagan he
just a few years after he got his phd
into a series called violent universe
and if you want to see carl sagan in
black and white
i've restored the footage check it out
on psyworks on youtube fantastic i've
not seen that i'm going to pop another
look
there you go i will have a look um
aaron has got to make a good point now
that's uh
um there's an episode as well where they
rescue some hippies
and then they start playing their thing
and feeling and they start singing a
song and spocs yourself stuff they're
watching and the only reason i like i do
like that episode is this it's really
really bad and but i can almost read
spock's brain of going up like
even he knows this is awful yeah and
they land them on this paradise and the
and the foliage is acidic eats through
their flip-flops or whatever
really you couldn't detect any more of
it
yeah i'm sure there's some more tng
episodes we've just forgotten about but
there's some bad ones anyway
let's call it an evening and again thank
you stormy very well done it's always a
pleasure to have my resident american on
and um
we'll see you next time guys thank you
very much for watching see you guys take
care